welcome back to new rock stars zack
snyder's justice league has restored the
snyder verse
if warner brothers will just decide to
like money
will this truly be the last we see of
snyder's dc
vision as it might be or or or
could snyder's justice league part two
and part three
now be in some future alternate timeline
that if we
run fast enough with our hopes we can
skew right into i'm eric boss not barry
allen i can't run
that fast watch our fitness videos
you'll see how capable i am of moving
physically
this is rogue theory with me is an
amazing panel i'm so excited to talk
about this with starting with the
co-host of our falcon winter soldier
after show
mt hey buddy hey buddy it's always good
to talk to you
and fellow nerds so this should be
really fun and with us as well
is friend of the show twitch streamer
angelica trey
hi it's good to be back i'm excited to
talk snyder cut
yeah good to have you back and returning
guest co-host of the film philosophers
podcast eddie villanueva
what is up guys i am excited to be here
i'm excited to talk about this stuff and
i'm ready to just dive right in and
let's do that so the snyder cut restored
snyder's vision for justice league
including the ways he intended the dc
movie universe to
carry on afterward into titles like the
batman when ben affleck was still just
gonna make it his movie
and the flash movie and uh movies like
justice league part
two and part three snyder himself has
sort of
kept that door open by suggesting that
hey if warner was willing to let him
recut justice league
letting him direct a follow-up film
isn't that more surprising
but snyder's also graciously
acknowledged that the theatrical cut
remains the dc eu cannon
because you know warner brothers has the
keys to the castle
and uh warner ceo and starring off
signaled that the snyder cut was really
the completion
of snyder's trilogy and she was kind of
hinting that they wanted to move on
and not rehash old directorial visions
like a david haircut
of suicide squad but panel let's help
warner see the light here because
this snyder cut gave this universe all
the tools it needs to have
an amazing thrilling showdown with a
justice league part two
and part three in the hands of snyder so
if uh
zack snyder's directing isn't up to your
taste viewer
that's totally fine you know you have
plenty of other dc titles to look
forward to
let's just let the fans have this moment
can we
and i want to ask all of you uh what
should and would a zack snyder justice
league part
2 look like now that we've all seen the
snyder cut i think the first thing we
have to
we have to honor in this particular
iteration of the snyder cut
is the fact that we get so much more of
cyborg and the heart of what this film
originally intended to put out that i
have no problem having the second part
build on top of cyborg's story and
continue that evolution of not only him
understanding his powers and abilities
but him just understanding and
recognizing and accepting himself
like i really hope that's the direction
that's one of the ideas that it's really
top of mind
moving forward because i am and i know
there's a lot of other ways to say this
but i am completely surprised that it
wasn't
in the original cut however in this
particular version
making his making his whole evolution
and hills his old story the heart of the
film
really gave light to a lot of things
that we could actually potentially see
down the road with dc
yeah uh agreed agreed and especially
there were little moments in here
like in that epilogue scene with uh with
the joker
in that post-apocalyptic future and how
cyborg seemed to be
kind of contesting batman for who was
really the leader of that gang he's like
we're exposed for too long how much
longer is it going to be to be there it
seemed like
uh cyborg had stepped up into more of a
leadership role which i really loved and
batman even kind of gave him that torch
when they both jumped on the flying fox
and he's like oh it's uh
it's it's want is to fly and he's like
it's yours too you know
so yeah i would definitely want cyborg
to be at the heart of that
yeah and i can totally see more because
basically in the snyder cut it fleshed
out a lot more
of cyborg and barry allen's
flash character and so it's setting up a
lot more
into part two even with the epilogue
how important these characters are and
just how much
space for growth their character arcs
could potentially have
and i think that's something that's
really exciting and something that
could and will would
likely you know take the spotlight in
justice league part two i want to see
more flash stuff
um in a future sequel because god uh
snyder really fixed that boy um
it was i mean obviously with cyborg as
well like
i just i'm very confused um
just how much we didn't like decided was
okay to cut
and like you know obviously josh joss
whedon you know he did the best we could
i guess with what he was doing
but like good god um the cyborg stuff
and the flash stuff
there's just a lot more like you just
love those characters more
and like i just i'm really interested to
see what they do with um you know
obviously with the canon
flashpoint movie that's that's coming
out yeah i really hope i mean i really
hope that warner brothers decides to tie
these two movies
into like well like uh zack snyder's
justice league anyway and make it canon
some way through
yeah the flashpoint movies because i
think that'd be really cool because i
think
snyder really did a really fantastic job
i say really like a zillion times so
that's that's just
we're here for it thank you we're really
here
the most incredible thing about this
movie is that everything had already
been shot except for five minutes of it
everything was already in can created
except for five minutes of a four-hour
epic event
that's insane that could have been the
first movie
right that's true which makes you think
maybe the snyder
you know snyder verse cannon was
underlying it all along
you know we could we could get we could
deep dive into this
like it was there and it was happening
or some of this stuff was happening you
know obviously not the things that were
edited
over um but but yeah like maybe
maybe it did happen maybe they can weave
it into
the the greater uh you know dc cannon
of the universe yeah i i don't see the
uh the cannon of the
snyder cut as too incompatible with the
with the theatrical cut just because the
theatrical cut just left questions
open-ended that the snyder cut just gave
us answers to
like all the you know the flash cameo
and batman v superman and that whole
nightmare
vision feature we weren't really sure
what that meant but if you just look
through the details of the snyder cut
it's like oh okay these characters
when a timeline has been altered by a
future
flash time reversal the characters who
are part of that timeline have
these kind of echoes of what happens in
that future and we see
we saw it happen with bruce and batman
superman we see it happen with cyborg in
this movie
right as barry allen is using his speed
force to reverse time
that's precisely when cyborg is like
whoa something just changed in the
future and we're now on a different
timeline
a different trajectory so you know i i
don't think
schneider's been really gracious about
it but just you know the way steppenwolf
is killed he's either way he's killed
either way there's a deeper threat
uh out there in the cosmos and you know
i don't think it's wrong for fans of the
snyder cut to feel like this is uh the
true direction of where this
universe is going yeah and here's the
thing here's something i've been uh
stewing over
uh a little bit after i watched the
snider cut because i was like this
movie's pretty good
and i was thinking since it's on hbo max
technically warner brothers could go
back and
fix any continuity issues in previous
films
on their site they could just literally
edit a little bit be like all right so
like this
this happened the snyder cup it didn't
happen in canada so we just put that in
and then give my boy snyder a sequel
because god it's such a
better film like i've gotta say it's
just so it's a lot it's a film
sorry no it was really good i um
i wish i could have seen what he would
have what snyder would have ended up
doing
when he probably would have had to cut
that down so it would have been
interesting to see how much
of that character building or you know
those extra scenes but
uh you know would have been cut down or
edited for the theatrical release
but i i thought i thought it did a lot
better in terms of fleshing out
characters
and uh representing steppenwolf let's
anchor some uh
plot points that seem to be headed
forward into
a part two so like we have in this
epilogue scene with lex luthor meeting
deathstroke and telling him that um that
batman is bruce wayne
and that was definitely setting up the
ben affleck batman story in which
deathstroke was going to be the
antagonist to that
but now deathstroke in this
post-apocalyptic epilogue scene is now
joining batman and his motley crew so it
seems like there's a defection
from this legion of doom that was going
to include lex deathstroke maybe the
joker and harley quinn
as well because we knew the original
plans to develop them in another movie
uh and then joker's decision it looks
like to kill lois lane in the bat cave
was such a screw-up move that ruined the
universe and turned superman in this
dark figure
that perhaps deathstroke is like whoa
buddy i mean we're mad at batman but
we're not going to burn the whole world
over it so it looks like that's what led
deathstroke to
defect do we think there were other
going to going to be other alternate
death sequences or other moments that
we're going to see play out as a result
of joker's actions
honestly it's endless because joker is
such a wild card
and you know we'll just let anything
happen
so that plus the
acknowledgement of a multiverse and with
all of you know barry allen
creating different timelines i
definitely think anything is possible
now and i was sitting there while
watching the snyder cut wondering
um if deathstroke if that was an
alternate timeline
you know in the epilogue versus just
that ending right beforehand because
death
stroke was so different and of course
there could be some
wild you know character arc that does
change things but i was just sitting
there wondering like
is this an alternate timeline and then
batman wakes up and i go was this whole
movie
just a dream super mario bros 2.
it was all a dream magazine
and i think we're overlooking one other
key one other key death in terms of the
one that could actually affect
the the outcome of how some of these
things will come to pass and that's
possibly the death of virus west you
know since we've introduced her into
this film
obviously barry is very fixated on her
that
slow motion you know touch and stare and
awkward a little weird
the hot dog part was my favorite i love
when he put that dog in his pocket and i
was like you're doing
an a-plus movie right there i could stop
the hot dog part was hilarious hot dog
like this boy hasn't eaten in days he's
just like yes for consumption
we're gonna save this for later it
wasn't that was an interesting shot for
sure
it was uh sweet and then it was like a
hot dog suddenly
yeah but the coming to pass of that
relationship
coming to fruition obviously we know
that we're gonna revisit that we know
we're gonna see
his full affection for her like fully
displayed in front of her and with her
and and the possibility of something
happening that causes the death of iris
west
that could cause barry to try to do
flashpoint
to create flashpoint and we could get
flashpoints
somewhere in between all of that that
could be the cause of it though him
trying to go back in time
yeah i mean he does have a lot of like
you know trauma with his mom and like
you know with the murder of his um
his mom and so like having like a a
romantic figure or
like a love figure um become lost like
would probably just
have him just be like if i can go back
in time i'm gonna do it i'm gonna say my
mom
and my boo so yeah i like that eddie
that's awesome and i wanna i wanna talk
more about
specifically flashpoint this flash movie
um a little bit later in the show but it
is a very important question how much
time hopping do you think snyder
intended to happen
in uh in justice league part two my
thinking is that
maybe he was uh expecting for that to be
explored in this flashpoint movie and
then there's maybe going to be some
alternate timeline maybe some time
reversal stuff but kind of like endgame
not overall a time travel story uh but
some kind of crossover event that is set
maybe mostly in
uh like in the present day as present
day batman is trying to connect with
joker and be like
what do i have to do to change your mind
to get you not to kill lois
and then we might have uh you know this
kind of a star trek next generation
finale thing where there's like multiple
timelines
ripple affecting each other like we know
where the future is but we're really
just staying focused on this
present day timeline of like a legion of
doom
and certain members of the legion of
doom being like look uh we're sorry that
joker did this like
having a batman versus joker
conversation
and that whole like jared leto ben
affleck moment of like
he brings up robin batman brings up
harley quinn
leto looks like scared in that moment
like i want to know what that was in
reference to
i want to see that moment and i'm
wondering if that's what this
part 2 was going to be yeah no that was
definitely a moment and that was
actually a really
good moment between ben affleck between
the bat
and the joker too and now i'm like
pondering into it because that was
actually
probably one of my favorite moments with
jared leto as joker
and there's there's definitely a lot of
a lot of different timeline suggestions
going on in there uh barry allen's now
got
he's got like armor too in that epilogue
so i'm wondering
you know if that helps in any way yeah
with th with the joker
maybe they could try to bring back
harley i don't know i feel like the bat
yeah a lot of it seems to be the key is
with joker
and then obviously throughout the movie
with like with lois it could essentially
be
a a portion derived from the injustice
storyline
where the joker tricks superman and
ultimately killing lois himself
which coming to find out she was also
pregnant at the time now obviously in
that
opening storyline superman goes to find
the joker in interrogation and kills him
now what if that's kind of part of the
reason why batman and the team
has joker to keep superman from finding
him and killing him
ultimately solidifying this next portion
of the apocalypse
and everything to come in the end so
you're saying that part two would be
extending out the apocalypse yeah
barry saw it and barry probably saw that
the yes
lois is the key but the i guess
the ignition would be the killing of
joker and everything following
suit yeah eddie i think uh you hit the
nail on the head there the
idea that i think injustice what is what
inspired snyder the most with this
post-apocalyptic scene having
a very dark superman who becomes
murderous essentially
uh and having to reconnect with him and
have him rediscover his humanity
but yeah joker's death uh the idea that
we see the torn
joker card in victor's vision tells us
that in some future timeline
batman broke the truce and just couldn't
take it anymore
this freaking clown taunted him and then
just beat him to death
because he was tired of it but that is
not what we see
at the end of the movie so there's we're
seeing multiple versions of events
and like batman batman's goal is like
how do i not
kill this freaking clown for what he's
done to me into the whole world
uh and joker's thing is like find the
right answer
find the key and his key is harley quinn
and i think that was what snyder was
hoping
there was gonna be a whole harley quinn
joker movie where you see the
relationship unfold and that
relationship is gonna be so important so
the idea for snyder what's more
important
like how do you make batman still
relevant in a cosmic battle
you know you gotta have his relationship
his history with the joker
and joker's history with harley quinn
matter and i feel like this is how you
make it matter
and for one uh just just going off of
what you said there eric
one of the things i would love to see is
like a harley quinn uh
origin story i just want to put that out
there but also
what if in the uh sorry what if
in part two they ended up doing
you know basically before the epilogue
uh you know continuing that with lex
luthor
and deathstroke and so they have that
where lex luthor
is now trying to i guess get to lois
because that's like the key to
everything they kept
they kept mentioning that throughout the
snyder cut lois is like the key
and everyone was was you know
emphasizing that
so i think that in part two it would be
lux luther
trying to kill lois you know maybe
figuring out that lois is
the key to superman and then having
deathstroke in the meantime
go after you know the batman and
and then maybe at the end of that part
two would
go back into another little snippet of
that post-apocalyptic looking epilogue
and continuing it like in little bites
yeah i agree with the little bites there
angelica because i think uh
if it were all set in this mad max
universe i think people would feel like
oh we have another bleak
post-apocalyptic
thing i think the smarter move is to
have it all set in the present day but
characters who just have
knowledge of what happens in the future
and then yeah we just see little like
flashes to
that post-apocalyptic future to see how
things are changing or to give like
flash forwards you know and lost how
they did flash forwards
yeah and you're trying to figure out
what happened in between the whole time
yeah
keep them yes and i think that would
that would fill in some of the
information of
the visit by john john's with
uh lois to keep her spirits high and not
kind of give up because if she passes
then that's i was just gonna say i think
that's interesting
how john johns knew that lois was the
key how much does he know about her
future
like is martian manhunter part of that
future as well and he's kind of just
this possibly
he must be i think yeah he knew way too
much
i think he's he's going to be one of
those like omniscient characters that
that pops in and pops out because like
sure he
i don't know he just he knew a little
too much and every time they
they brought him in which was pretty
sparingly throughout the snyder cut
it was because of that you know you
can't have a character that's like
too all-knowing they have to be a little
cryptic with it otherwise like
they're just gonna tell everything
they're gonna spill all um i also think
when they included um so they they
included a little bit
of the atom uh you know like the
scientists
set up etc i think that they might yeah
they might
tie him into a part two as well yeah i
think uh
i think the atom would show up and i
think green lantern a lot of people are
asking like where's hal jordan or jon
stewart
uh and i think snyder has said he wanted
green lantern to
show up in uh part three of this
because once you bring in the green
lantern court like you could see the way
zack snyder
handled green lantern in this movie he's
like well we have the one in the ancient
battle he gets killed off and then we'll
have kilowog show up in the ruins of the
hall of justice
but it's i i don't know how interested
in the character
zack snyder is i actually believe that
warner said that he couldn't use the
lanterns
oh was that it yeah because i remember i
think i read an article a couple days
ago where
like warner was like yeah green lantern
didn't do too good so we're just gonna
avoid the lanterns
yeah that's a long walk home for for
this particular
character we got a lot of cleanup to do
before we can get to that
fair enough yeah uh and i know they
wanted to have a green lantern corps
movie at some point like around 2016
2017 there were talks
there was gonna be a green lantern corps
movie in like 2022 or something like
that
i think that's all been scrapped now and
now they have uh berlanti is doing a
green lantern core
show for yeah i think right yeah yes um
so uh i want to cap this off with uh
snyder kind of teased that
he actually had names for justice league
part two and justly part three he had a
big document with just like name after
name afternoon it wasn't just gonna be
the number
it was gonna you know like we had batman
v superman dawn of justice and the
justice
league and the justice league right
something so i wanna hear you guys pitch
is for what do you think part two and
part three were going to be named it's
hard to not say end game that's all i'm
saying
i mean in my head i've already set it up
as part two
being centered around lex luthor and
deathstroke and solex is going after
superman through lois and
deathstroke is going obviously for the
batman because an eye for an eye
that joke and it's all set up
so i'm thinking something along the
lines of
of uh
let's see like lux
lex lux luther
aft i want like an alliteration here lex
luthor
gets lois or like i don't know i can't
think of like a good word for it like
lex luthor loves leaflets lovely
lollipops
and then part three i would think
they would tie in darkseid again looking
for the anti-life equation
on earth somewhere in my head for some
reason
i've got it like in in a snyder cut or
snyder verse version like in the
pyramids for some reason but
um it would be like return to the dark
side or something you know
like part three returned to the dark
side and it spelt like dark side
yeah casting mark hamill as a joker
would be somewhere in there
yeah that would be amazing
um i would call a justice league sequel
honestly just straight up
injustice because the injustice series
is very popular and it deals with an
evil superman
and people who see that would probably
be i just see the title
would probably just be like oh i know
what this is about and like this is very
intriguing
so i think they would just call it
injustice and then justice league three
would probably just be like
the return of justice more justice
justice is back
yeah and so i that's just me all the
justice
i like extra justice i feel like if
there's one thing there's one thing that
encapsulates
every solid dc eu movie and by that i
just mean man of steel
um i agree one thing that encapsulates
all of the dceu films and what they try
to run through that one common thread is
relationships that's what each film is
built upon you know if you look at man
of steel the relationship between
superman and his
fathers and this relationship between
him and lewis and the relationship
between him
and earthlings you look at the next one
it's a relationship with you know uh
batman and him understanding who mar who
clark is and it's based on relationships
that's why this one this particular
justice league was so successful
uh the relationship between cyborg and
his parents the relationship between him
his relationship with him and the mother
box
and then him with himself that's what
made it so successful
that's why it's such an enduring film so
i feel like
if we're gonna pitch part two and part
three i would say part two would be
justice league love lost because we're
going to look at
possibly losing two key love interests
with lois
and or possibly iris west and then the
last one's going to have to be
justice league lost paradise because
we're going to look at
where justice league is going to be
already in that apocalyptic state and if
you've read the comics or seen anything
there's a series called justice league
dark apocalypse war
where everything just goes all over the
place it goes to [ __ ] and
uh they go for one last chance and it
still is there's a lot of casualties
people are gone and at the tail end
it the decision is to send barry back in
time to rewind time to fix it
and that's how it ends and so i'm
thinking if you're zack snyder
and if you're wanting to ensure future
uh occupational opportunities at the end
of justice league three you're gonna
make it so it's an open-ended
opportunity to come back
and fill in the gaps of that very very
good take claire uh this is still
rogue theory guys so despite it being
just a nice conversation i'm still
mentally awarding points because i just
have that kind of brain
uh so just to give a point for this
round i'm gonna give a golden sparkle
book to eddie i liked your titles there
at the end i think
you have a pretty good take for for
where this would be i would love to see
all three of your
uh versions of plot events for the
future uh
but uh eddie i think has the edge of the
one i would go see first
uh and then i would say restore the
empty cut
and restore the angelica and they would
go back and forth
yeah who's to say what is the true canon
going forward
um but good job all three of you guys
we're gonna talk more about the dceu
future that the snyder cuts set up but
first we want to thank some people who
help sponsor us starting with audible
thank you to audible for sponsoring this
episode audible is the leading provider
of spoken word entertainment
all in one place at audible you can find
the largest selection of audiobooks
from bestsellers new releases to
celebrity memoirs and more
they have original entertainment from
top celebrity creators and thousands of
popular and binge-worthy podcasts
and they've got everything you want lord
of the rings stephen king star wars
novels
and all of the game of thrones you'll
need to catch up on before all these new
series come out because there's like six
of them now
uh i'm really into their exclusive
podcasts they have some great stuff
about hollywood history
and they have enough true crime content
to make you want to double check your
deadbolt at night
uh audible fits right into your
lifestyle listen to audiobooks when you
do chores or exercises just carve out a
little me time for yourself and slip
into that new pulp thriller or that
classic that has been on your to-do list
since junior high
with everything you love to listen to
all in one app audible plus is like your
playlist for life new members can always
try audible plus for
30 days for free visit audible.com
rogue theory or text rogue theory to 500
500
again that's audible.com rogue theory or
text bro theory to 500 500
we also want to thank our friends at
blue chew for sponsoring this episode
so our buddies at blue chew have a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra in
cialis
but in a chewable form that is at a
fraction of the cost
but at least two whole numbers more
than you would normally get uh on an
average day
in other ways blue chew is an online
prescription service so no doctor's
office or pharmacy trips it ships right
to your door in
a discreet package but your package will
be anything but discreet
you sign up at bluechew.com consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days
their licensed medical providers work
with you to find the right ingredient
and strength
so if you hate swallowing pills good
news folks blue chew is chewable
like it says in the name so if you could
benefit from extra confidence when it's
time to perform visit bluetooth.com for
more details and important safety
information
and we've got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth free when you use
our promo code
rogue at checkout just pay the five
dollars of shipping that's bluechew.com
promo code rogue
to receive your first month for free and
we thank bluetooth for sponsoring this
podcast and giving us the
the giddy little school kids laughs that
we have when we talk about it and new
rockstars
also wants to thank stereo for
sponsoring us we've been partnering with
the stereo app on a whole new slate of
exclusive
shows we're putting up almost as much
content on stereo as we are on youtube i
don't know how we're doing it all at
once but we're making it work
uh most of this stuff only exists on
stereo which is free and you can get by
going to stereo.com
new rockstars every week we're pumping
out at least four shows there folks we
preview what's coming up in pop culture
like when new rock stars news on
wednesdays and our falcon winter soldier
preview show on thursdays
and then we're reviewing what's already
out there and our inside marvel reaction
show on fridays with the
mt and then we have an editor show on
mondays and the best part of stereo is
you get to be a part of the show you
submit audio messages with your
questions and your theories and your
reactions and we'll play those voice
messages and react to them in real time
sometimes it'll even show up on the
youtube channel later so you'll be a
star
baby and right now you can go back and
listen to all of our previous episodes
on any of our shows on the stereo app
and you access these live shows to share
your questions and theories and interact
with us in real time by downloading the
free stereo app at stereo dot com slash
new rockstars at stereo dot com slash
new rockstars
all right let's get back to the snyder
cut so it's most dramatic change to the
rules of the dc world really involved
barry allen reversing time
first he used this speed board to
reverse that mother box during
superman's resurrection scene in the
kryptonian chamber
and then in the final act whoa to
reverse the whole motherbox unity and
the world's destruction
insane now these moves plus a bunch of
other little clues around barry's father
henry allen
saying stuff like i don't want you to
run in place on a treadmill
or you know talking about his mother's
unexplained mystery murder
uh this is all setting up the upcoming
flash movie it's coming november 2022.
it's gonna adapt the flashpoint paradox
comics in which barry allen
really just runs back in time to try to
prevent his mother's murder
but in doing so skews up all the
timelines of the dc world so this movie
event is going to be an insane crossover
event it's going to feature ben affleck
batman
but also michael keaton batman there's
talk of danny devito penguin and jeffrey
dean morgan as thomas wayne showing up
let's try to clear up the flash timeline
logic that snyder presented
in his cut of the justice league and
look ahead to what this will mean for
this 2022 flash
movie so first off
what do we think uh what alternate
timelines did we
see in the snyder cut what was an
alternate timeline what was the timeline
we're currently on
do we have any guesses there i mean
obviously that nightmare timeline like
whenever
when i saw like deathstroke and mera
like all i got was um
was flashes of no pun intended of the
flashpoint paradox cartoon movie
animated movie
um which is fantastic if you guys have
not seen that film
you have to see it like that was my
first experience with the
flashpoint paradise it is a phenomenal
uh work
uh but yeah it it it had um like all
these dc
characters in different roles because
like everything the timeline was messed
up
so like obviously that nightmare
scenario is
is going to be its own timeline and i do
believe that we're going to see that
again
in uh flashpoint paradox um with
possibly even
two berries um interacting and just be
like oh
hey barry from the snyder cut hello a
dusty world barry
let's maybe work together who knows
we've already gotten a hint of that from
the uh
the arrowverse the the cw series where
you know ezra miller showed up and there
was like the two berries talking to each
other and that is canon it's tying in
that arrowverse and folding it into the
dceu in a cool
way so yeah i think we've already seen a
bit of that we'll probably see more of
it
and if there's anything that we can we
can attribute to the grant gustin series
it's that it's given more life into
what not many people know about the
flash storyline and
obviously a very key important character
in
the flashpoint uh series
is eobard thon you know reverse flash
and the the instigation if you will that
eobard does to barry to
cause him to create that secondary
timeline um i do think though that we
actually witnessed a portion of that
timeline creation secondary timeline
creation
with that uh going back in time
ultimately creating two different
parallels with
one where like you were saying the
apocalypse did happen and this is who's
left
and then the one that was saved and i
and i feel like
they're gonna take whoever takes the
wheels from here for the flash movies
and so forth
um they're gonna take it on a more
literal sense every time
time is rewound a new timeline is
created in any instance no corrections
i mean if there's any ins there's any
example of that it's it's been in the
modern
uh interpretations of like the rebirth
and new 52s and and dc comics
where we see kind of the wrap up if you
will of the flashpoint
series um so i really feel like we're
going to create
several timelines ultimately kind of
surpassing
odd to say marvel in their ability to
create multiple timelines as of yet yeah
if they can get this out and done in
time and well enough
yeah and i i definitely think you know
just just going off of what eddie said
when they do release this movie it's
gonna be extremely chaotic because we're
seeing barry allen
afraid of his ability to do this
you know he he just kind of vaguely says
time
what does he say like time gets weird or
something
very vague yeah it's like uh the rules
he's like when i approach the speed of
light
uh i start to break time or something
yeah yeah he's afraid of it
so he's going to be uh so to speak
running head first
into this and then probably trying to
correct whatever timelines happen we've
seen it in the past
with the flashpoint paradox where he has
barry allen has gone
to a timeline where he doesn't have his
powers where
maybe batman's parents live but
but bruce wayne dies we've seen many
different timelines here and there's so
many characters that you can play with
and characters that you can work with
and then of course now with the snyder
verse we've got that
the nightmare alternate timeline too and
so
i definitely think that there's a lot of
potential for this movie to be
chaotic but in the best way possible and
it'd be a great shoe in to
introduce uh jay garrick at the tail end
when you have this fumbling
barry who's going all over the place and
creating all these multiple timelines
almost comedic to where it's like where
i can fix this i can fix this and then
at the tail end jay shows up he's like
look son let me show you how it's done
right yeah that's a good point i mean
when they did uh when andy muschietti
and ezra miller
in the flash team christina hudson
showed up to talk about their flash
movie just a five minute segment at dc
fandom in august
like they were kind of indicating that
they're not afraid to pull in
any element from any past dc uh warner
brothers
adaptation i mean they showed freaking
constantine
uh they showed all the different batman
i think the only one they didn't show
was christian bale
uh because i think they're still pretty
protective of what nolan created
but like yeah the fact they're bringing
in michael keaton maybe danny devito
they could dc is in a position right now
to
do the multiverse so much better than
what
marvel has done so far
in one division we didn't really see the
multiverse blow up yet
end game i would say kind of backpedaled
from the implications they created of
alternate timelines
like even the directors and the
screenwriters of end game were not on
the same page
of what the multiverse implications of
their movie was whereas right now
mushietti
uh seems like ready to dive in head
first
because it's like they have nothing to
lose because people have been like
criticizing this cinematic universe
for its inconsistencies and now they're
just like all right we're just going to
say that the flash did all of this
like give me a rake we're going to start
from the beginning and just scoop it all
in
just yeah blame it all on barry
uh just ezra miller's sense of humor and
mushy eddie's abilities as a director
if they can get cameos by michael keaton
in this hell go crazy with it
and then yeah on the other side of it
you do a new 52 rebirth you have robert
pattinson batman and this is what it is
going forward
hold up let me ask you guys a question
because something just popped into my
head
how would you feel if zack snyder said
guess what guys watchmen how would you
guys feel about that
if like somehow the flashpoint movie
introduced the watchman characters from
that film
um that he directed years ago funny that
you say
uh there is a current well it just
finished current series
uh called doomsday clock where they've
actually brought
back due to barry allen's uh
instigating of the speed force and the
timelines brings back
into the current six one six i'm sorry
in the current earth one sorry
jumping things earth one um brings the
watchman into
that particular universe and essentially
creates this
storyline where dr manhattan was the one
who had essentially manipulated the
the time uh timelines in the speed force
and
created these multiple timelines to
determine if humanity can
actually be gracious and humane to each
other
as a test that's awesome so uh the
storyline is a really great story it's a
12 month issue
run um and everything oddly enough
spoiler alert
oddly enough everything surrounds
superman
and why the only reason why dr manhattan
does not destroy the world itself and
create a new one
is because superman is that one last
shred of of hope that
humanity can still be genuine to each
other
yeah i love that idea and like in that
flash panel at dc fandom they they
referenced watchmen i'm pretty sure it
was the hbo
watchman and not the zack snyder
watchman which is even crazier
if they try to bring in bring in regina
king i'm cool
she's awesome um but yeah i'm i'm so
excited for this flash movie
and a lot of people are saying that
spider-man uh no way home is gonna be a
multiverse story the more we see about
it the more i'm thinking
i don't know if we're gonna see toby and
andy show up in there
yeah i think the but i do think this
flash movie it's like
we could get real bonkers oh yeah oh
yeah for sure
no bear i could see barry allen getting
comfortable with
you know changing these timelines to the
point where he ends up like
changing the course of things just for a
hot dog again
just going back to that whole you know
what i mean like he's like oh no the hot
dog fell
and he like goes back in time creates
another timeline just to like save a hot
dog
i think that's what i would do they
could get really zany with it yeah
i i would say it would be a fun little
campaign
if they started doing hashtag barry gave
us
bat nipples yeah that's what i'm saying
[Laughter]
i love that so much oh there's so much
work
i really do hope because like as we saw
in shows like smallville
and not just in uh cw shows these dc
actors keep coming back
uh lionel luther in smallville was the
doctor to poison ivy in
uh batman and robin same actor uh martha
kent
what played lana lang in uh superman
three
um in smallville and uh yeah if you
follow these
cw airbus shows like they they all keep
bringing back people
all the time so yeah if they could find
a way to bring in all these cameos in
this movie
oh i'd love to see a scarecrow or
something
oh my god yeah scarecrow
scarecrow needs more screen time so uh
i gotta give the point again to eddie on
that one bringing that whole uh
uh watchman and finding the way to link
that together i think that'd be great so
you're getting the point there
um but it's still anyone's game because
we got a couple rogue questions coming
up
uh so first question the first episode
of the falcon winter soldier brought up
some
good questions about how the avengers
get paid
so uh the question is do you think the
avengers should be paid and if so
what should their income be and uh
how why how would they justify their pay
raises and stuff like that
like how high of a risk you know maybe
like you've got
you know i i'm not sure here but you're
right
hazard pay should kick in yeah exactly
and like there
there's overtime there's holiday too
[Laughter]
take a holiday batman crime will wait
there's retirement like there's a 401k
or something involved in there
yeah oh so you mean hourly as a good
thing not like uh
because if it's salary that's all they
get paid but if they can get uh clock in
some ot
in there yeah because if someone so they
can pay more exactly if someone's doing
higher risk longer you know jobs
essentially then then they should be i
don't know honestly i don't
i don't want to make any statements here
because i feel like everyone's going to
argue with me in the comments but like
but i'd say that you know some of the if
there are
any any you know characters that are
like doing more
i would hope that they would be
compensated in some way
okay we should have jay jonah jameson
head the avengers and paid them by the
job
terribly paid by the trash wow
yeah yeah
but i think that if the avengers do get
paid i think that they should get paid
very little because
um falcon in the episode one of falcon
in the winter soldier
said that it was mainly based in
goodwill and i feel like once you start
you know paying people and becoming
heroes for hire
luke cage shout out hey um then like
more people will try to i don't know
become avengers
like mysterio in a way just like you
know like i want to be an avenger
because like that's a great pain
like that's a job and that would be fun
to see though i'd watch that no
making the college football payment
argument like oh they're getting paid in
education
you're doing it for the love of the game
so i disagree i honestly think that you
know
this is like a volunteer thing and then
like people with really good hearts
should become avengers
they're paid in good karma sure yeah
just starting but they should be at
least given some
salary they can yeah they should they
should be getting like some
a livable weight but nothing like super
crazy that entire
entices people to like want to become a
hero just
just to get paid i don't know for the
money how about this like they
at least fund their their housing
right yes like their technology
yeah like the essentials are covered and
then
beyond that you know it's it's it's lit
but when they get injured on the job
they're done sorry no retirement
we don't pay health insurance here just
figure it out all right
very true very true grab some ice i i
would say we would have to like
incorporate something like uh like in
one punch man create like a system where
they get paid if they're consistent
every week and something and
they'll get like a stipend every week
because yes
they are they are heroes and they do it
out of the goodness of their heart
yes they should get something but the
thing is it goes back to where is it
going to come from who's going to who's
going to foot that bill and
it's just it's really interesting how it
gets into the weeds of all that
but yeah i think there should be like a
tiered system where the more they go up
and rank as
a superhero the more they'll get paid
yeah i think that's a sensible answer
however all three of you are wrong the
correct answer is capital should be
abolished and people should be giving
a universal basic income and no one
should be
participating in the evil capitalist
structure your assigned reading is a
communist manifesto by karl marx i was
just gonna say that sounds very common
i was the closest with covering their
house like their housing you were
you were so angelica gets a point see
look i don't i don't get paid because
i'm not
cause i'm i don't that's what i wanted i
just didn't want to get paid so i just
don't have any bucks there
that's why this is the future i decided
for myself
yeah there is yeah great you're in
future yep
um all right another question here march
26th
which could be tomorrow depending on
when you're seeing this uh has been
declared
leonard nimoy day in boston in
recreation of the boston-born spock
actor so what is the best way to
celebrate leonard neymar
leonard nimoy day everybody find an
opportunity to
find william shatner and kick him down
oh my god
i just turned to 90. he just changed
today
his birthday is literally filming right
now
he's kicking his ass on his birthday why
not oh my god birthday beatings
to a 90 year old man let's just do that
for leonard well as a truckee i would
have to say
that um you'd have to go around for
the entire day using extreme logic
and raising one eyebrow
uh-huh you know yeah spa style yeah
spock would like that you can you can
greet people like this too
because honestly it's good for
you know the current situation you don't
have to touch anybody
just go like this right yeah that's true
honestly i i say we all just do spock
shots on the 26th
just shots you know just uh it's just a
regular shot but like you just
you hold it like this i just said oh it
could be anything yeah
it's just like it's pinky and ring
finger outside
like penguin
this is more like ninja turtle to me
sort of like yeah
i love it anyway hashtag spot shots
shots are they
and i'm in boston right now so like it's
about to be lit over here on letter knee
more though
um i'm giving mt the point for spock
shot oh
thank you so well done but i think if my
math is correct uh
eddie villanueva is our winner
rightfully so
well done well done to all of you this
has been such an enlightening
conversation i could talk with you guys
for hours and hours
longer than an hour no one clicks on the
video so
that is it for this episode of rogue
theory i want to thank all three of our
guests empty
angelica trey and eddie villanueva
follow all of them
on their social medias uh support them
wherever they are
show them some love and uh support this
channel by checking out one of our many
great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me at eavos
follow new rockstar
subscribe here on youtube and a reminder
to download the stereo app by going to
stereo dot com slash new rockstars you
can listen to our four new weekly live
shows
including inside marvel with myself and
mt talking about the whatever the
episode [ __ ] winter soldier is and you
can download this app for free
on apple and android and create an
avatar profile and i'll see you next
time everybody
see you in some other future don't you
dare since some boy wonders to do a
man's job
[Music]
you